can you tell us about it hey everybody
its charlie we have the best possible
news early in the week so what happened
is is HBO dropped that promo for Game of
Thrones season 8 and all their other
prestige series they're premiering in
the first half of 2019 there were a lot
of reports from the visual effects
department that there were going to be
potential delays they thought they were
gonna miss the Emmys cut off right after
that like really late Sunday night after
that all came out after I posted my
video HBO came out and made an official
clarification about when they would be
airing episodes and it's way earlier
than what these visual effects people
were talking about so we got to talk
about that we also learn more about the
prequel series when they'll probably be
dropping footage and the winds of winter
release state so I'll explain that stuff
at the end of the video we'll talk about
season 8 first if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos there's new giveaway stuff at
the end of the video too so here's what
happened after all these big news sites
were reporting the game of Thrones
might be delayed you with my beginning
and much later than we thought so
naturally to be expected people started
freaking out so of course HBO got really
pissed off so what happened is as they
use Entertainment Weekly is a bit of a
mouthpiece for information that they
want to convey like it's basically like
please post this comment on the trailer
when you post it on your website the
full statement reads Game of Thrones
returns for its final six episodes that
will air during the first half of 2019
there had been reports over the weekend
claiming that the show's return had been
delayed quote-unquote to mid 2019 making
it not eligible for Emmys until 2020
rest assured first half of 2019 means
exactly that an HBO expects the show
will air all of its episodes in time for
the 2019 any eligibility cutoff so
that's really awesome that they came out
and said that I'm happy that they
clarified but the most important line of
dialogue in that statement is is that
the show will air all of its episodes
before the Emmys cut up the Emmys cut
off is May 31st there are six episodes
total in season eight if the visual
effects supervisor said that he thought
that they would miss the Emmys cut off
because visual effects are taking too
long to complete then that means per HBO
they'll probably drop it at the latest
possible date that
allows them to air all the episodes
before the May 31st cutoff which would
be April 22nd 2019 they probably just
totally fired that effects supervisor
that said that they were going to delay
his season aids so pouring out for him
first official casualty of the season so
yeah that's really awesome but here's
the really cool Easter Egg in that
particular April 22nd date because it is
the eighth year anniversary of the
weekend that the pilot aired so I don't
think there's any kind of grand
conspiracy I think it's just a
coincidence if they finished episodes
earlier than that they would drop them
sooner but because the way visual
effects are going and the fact that they
waited longer to film and they spent
longer filming each episode it just
takes them longer in production most of
the earlier seasons actually aired in
early to mid April it wasn't really
until season 6 and season 7 that we
started to see more delays and a lot of
that just has to do with the increased
scale and the fact that they weren't
adapting the books anymore it's a lot
easier to adapt a TV show when you still
have material left to adapt so like they
were basically just taking portions of
the books and turning that into TV
episodes when they got to season 6 they
had to start making it more original
material and that's a lot harder to do
even though George our Martin sort of
told them his outline for how the
characters would be panning out and gave
them an idea for what the ending of the
story was going to be this new report
from HBO about the April date just jives
a lot more with what Maisie Williams
said a little while ago about them
having a spring release date instead of
a summer release date and also with what
sir Davos was saying at the beginning of
filming right after they got scripts and
I do have some news that nobody else
knows the reason being I only got this
news what day is today what's today
Friday so we got this I got an email on
Wednesday okay let me tell you what's
happening to me next week I have to
leave here on Sunday and then I get in a
car and I go straight up to Belfast
where we are having the first do you
call a table read a read-through
non-temporary James we have the first
table read on Sunday of the of three
episodes on Sunday and then on Monday we
read the next three and that's so that's
Monday then we have then we rehearse for
the rest of that
we were there two of the directors
there's three directors for the final
six and then we start filming
I think officially it's either the 16th
or the 19th of October so what's that
three weeks time yeah three three three
weeks twelve we start you gotta love sur
Davos he's kind of like the Tom Holland
Mark Ruffalo of Game of Thrones just
accidentally giving away information
about the show that he's not supposed to
when I posted that trailer video a
couple days ago I also talked about the
filming dates for the long night prequel
series so they'll start filming in
February which is awesome news because
that means that they'll also be able to
hit that April spring release date for
2020 I've still seen a lot of comments
about people not having any idea of
what's going on with this long night
prequel series people thinking that
there's not going to be any more Game of
Thrones after season 8 is done so I will
do more prequel videos as we get more
information about that but just a
reminder the prequel series will be the
ancestors of the characters in present
day so it's going to be said 10,000
years in the past meaning the only
potential crossover characters could be
the three-eyed Raven or brand because
they can see into the past even though
I'm not expecting them to cross over
into that series it'll cover the
mythical long night that's talked about
in the Citadel and old Nan's
tales I spiders big as hounds that's
what we're talking about what they're
probably gonna do is they'll release the
first teaser for that after the season 8
finale airs just to strike while the
iron is hot while they have you know 20
plus million people watching that finale
just to get everybody hyped up for seven
or eight more years of Game of Thrones
because you have to remember that even
though they say like two million or so
average people watch my Game of Thrones
episode videos they were like 20 to 25
million people watching Game of Thrones
episodes last year most of those 25 some
odd million people who watch Game of
Thrones statistically only subscribe to
HBO when they're airing new Game of
Thrones episodes that's hundreds of
millions of dollars in subscription
money that they earn so HBO just wants
to let all those people not to cancel
their subscriptions after the season 8
finale because we have this shiny new
Game of Thrones series that's coming
really soon
next spring so yeah just expect them
start pushing that hard starting next
summer after the air the season 8 finale
so I will totally do videos when we find
out new information about it there was a
new report about winds of winter
potentially being released next year as
well from a foreign language translator
that works on the Song of Ice and Fire
titles for the publisher he was saying
that based on the page count that George
R Martin had been submitting to the
publisher
he expected fully that they would be
releasing the book sometime next year
now I obviously take that with a grain
of salt but he is somebody that's
associated with the publishers that
translate Song of Ice and Fire books
into foreign languages in Europe so the
call is coming from inside the castle
it's a little more legit than just your
average speculator but if it really does
release next year I wouldn't expect that
till a little bit later in the year but
it looks like what we'll have is is will
have winds of winter to bridge the gap
between the end of the main series and
the beginning of the prequel series so
when we get that I will do more book
videos and we do have the fire and blood
book that's coming out later this year
in November I'll do videos for that too
when it comes out in the meantime leave
all your requests for Game of Thrones
videos in the comments there's a new
round to that 4k blu-ray giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
leave a comment on the video
congratulations to the winner from my
last big video M Holman please email me
on the about page of my youtube channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for my video about the new Jon
Sansa episode one scene and click here
to rewatch that promo thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome see
you guys tonight